because we're going to see temperatures
drop into the 70s for a couple of days
this week in the meantime we'll also
have chances for rain of course we're
looking live at allegiant stadium the
raiders are playing tonight on monday
night but not at home they're taking on
the chargers down in socal officially
we're at 70 degrees but what's happening
in your neighborhood we have seen the
temperatures even dropping some more mid
60s for aliante at the air force base 68
sunrise mountain 69 henderson still
hanging on to 70 for downtown the strip
and summerlin
kyle cannon cooler at 50 better chances
for rain up on the mountain
this is going to be for tomorrow more
right now numbers for nevada and beyond
76 over in death valley good morning to
prep with a 65 and howdy debate he don't
say hi to you guys enough and a cooler
morning for ely but not as cool as last
week they were down in the 20s for a
couple of mornings last week so we did
91 yesterday it was well above normal no
threat to any records but we're going
for 88 today which would still be above
normal our current temperature the low
so far we think we may drop one more
degree before things start to warm up so
yes we are talking about scattered
showers tomorrow no big accumulation got
an area of low pressure that is parked
off the southern california coast so
those clouds continue to roll up this
way we'll keep an eye on it and then it
should roll out of here fairly quickly
for your family and friends a fairly
quiet weather day some scattered showers
for parts of michigan eastern
pennsylvania riding on up into new york
but not too much going on along the deep
south which is great after all of the
devastation they've had the past month
or so so after 88 today look at the high
temperature dropping to 80 for tomorrow
again those scattered showers clouds
linger for wednesday and thursday we
bring back another slider chance for
rain on friday but there's that high
temperature drop into the 70s morning
lows maybe in the 50s as we get into the
weekend we'll talk more about that